in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Lonnie
and Yolanda are with us hey guys how are
you hello how you doing dude I'm better
than I deserve
welcome welcome where you guys live
swanny Georgia fun fun well thank you
for visiting us here in Nashville so
you're here to do a debt-free scream yes
how much of you paid off a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars I love it and
how long did that take 50 months 15 15
15 months making what kind of income
household during that time when we
started was about 160 and I got a raise
and it ended at about 187 from our tax
returns last year excellent what do you
guys do for a living well I'm retired
Air Force officer and slash their home
dad um I started doing that probably
after I retired from the Air Force and I
made a commitment to say okay you you
you can make more money now I could stay
home and take care of a little girl and
and that's kind of what would happen
that's fun okay and what do you do you
London I'm a nurse practitioner slash
nurse midwife I deliver babies very fun
good for you guys
excellent so what kind of debt was the
hundred and twenty thousand dollars at
home you pay off your house y'all are
weird
you're completely weird we love being
weird I love it congratulations so
what's this house worth probably if we
put it on the market mile to sixty five
to three hundred phenomenal way to go I
love it congratulations thank you thank
you don't have a house payment
nope I love it so what happened 15
months ago that made you decide you're
gonna lean in on this thing well we
started following you back in 2004 we
paid off all of our commercial kind of
debt and after that we started doing
after we got our three to six month
emergency fund we started doing four or
five and six mm-hmm and we were doing
that we were like you know you said it
only takes about seven years afterwards
like that is too long and we kept I kept
putting numbers down I'll say oh if we
pay $100 more and that'll be an extra
payment a year and I was like if we had
$1,000 extra every time I kept putting
more and more money I said do you know
if we could put this much money down a
month we could be done in a year and a
half three years and so I looked at him
and he was like okay now yeah she's on a
roll so you rolled up your sleeves and
lived on beans and rice while making
serious money but still knock this out
in a short period of time
congratulations very well done very well
done so how long have you guys been
married 30 years have you ever been
without that during your marriage we
have been but we would kind of always go
back because we both had good incomes
and we said well we can pay our bills so
what difference does it make if we have
a credit card here or we have this and
that but so you had your home paid off
before no we've never had our home paid
off program had like commercial debt and
we've only had a mortgage I see good now
you're 100% though have you ever been
100% never will you ever go back oh
definitely not okay even with the big
income okay way to go y'all so what do
you tell people the secret to paying off
your house is you have to want it you
have to work together mm-hmm and you
have to be on the same page and you have
to think about all of that stuff that
the media wants you to buy and spend
your money on when I hear you say you
know we make too much money to be broke
and that's what I would tell my husband
and you know all of your income coming
in the media our marketers want it going
out and when you can keep your money to
yourself how much more can you do not
only for yourself I always said in our
church if everybody was debt-free what
could we do you know and so that was the
whole key
you can live like nobody else if you're
willing to live like no one else there
you go so so Lonnie what do you say the
key to getting out of debt is the key is
to always be cooperative and follow what
your wife's they do and be sure that her
name is Yolanda that's great yeah I
thought I was right once but she
corrected me yeah I understand I
completely understand well
congratulations you two very very well
done how long you been married 30 plus
years or 30 or 30 years and a couple
couple of weeks no congratulations
okay so if you were doing it over it
being the money piece of the equation
there's a couple out there I just hung
up with a guy that's getting married
December 5th what's your advice to that
couple that's just getting started if
they haven't taken FPU sign up and go
straight and take FPU Wow thank you and
after that I would say learn to live on
less than you make and what I tell my
daughter who just graduated debt-free
when you think about buying a house like
we never knew that you could buy a house
cash just I mean you could but we never
thought we could do it hmm so I tell my
daughter I said buy a house cash in the
very beginning a very important key is
your relationship relationship is very
important in any type of endeavor and
what I realized I've known as quite some
time that if your relationship is strong
then things tend to fall into place
because the key is a strong relationship
then you can build on doing some other
good things in your marriage or whatever
you doing absolutely very well very
well-spoken great job you guys I'm proud
of you proud for you life is good you
got no house payment man all right
and Yolanda from Suwanee Georgia 120,000
dollars paid off house and everything
debt-free 15 months making 160 187 count
it down let's get a debt-free scream man
that's awesome well done you two